Serena Williams to serve.
When the world writes her down in history,...
...we'll begin where she started:...
...at love.
No points, zero score, just love.
It's a love that will remember through the generations,...
...a love that started a movement,...
...a movement to always love exactly who you are and who you can be.
To be so in love with your identity...
...that your very essence cannot be contained.
To love the sound of your own voice and the way you move.
To feel like a queen unapologetically with a crown indefinitely.
To cherish every muscle and every curve your body exhibits.
A movement to always love being a proud black woman.
A parent.
A dreamer.
A leader.
Yes, ladies, it can be done.
To love being one of a kind.
To always love being you.
The whole you.
The real you.
You, you, you, to always love you.
So when we write her down in history,...
...no matter who you are,...
...no matter where you are,...
...we'll remember what she has shown us:...
...a movement to love you.